Bugün size Anlatacağımız Konu
sürdürülebilirlik başlığı altında devam
mı tamam mı Ve benim slaytım var Bugün
size anlatacağım ve hepsi hayatımda şu
deniyor şundan bahsediyorum ben size İyi
olan kazansın diyorum Aslında Tamam
dediklerimiz İyi devam dediklerimiz İyi
tamam dediklerimiz kötü çerçevede
düşünebilirsiniz Aslında bugün konuşmama
Keşke de gelseydi diye düşünmedim
şu an galiba 18 yaşında Sizin yaş
grubunuzdayken biliyorsunuz 2018'de
iklim zirvesinde bir eylem yaptı çok
aktivist bir eylemim vardı ve dedi ki
artık bıla buna ben hiç unutmayalım
artık Boş boş konuşmayın ve sonu
eğlenmeye geçin dedi eee sizlerin dedi
ahlaki ve vicdanı toplum ve ahlaki ve
vicdanı sorumlulukları var dedi Ve
bizlerin somut olarak artık dedi ee
mücadelesine yönelik adımlar atmamız
toplumların iyileşmesine yönelik adımlar
atmamız gerektiğini söyledi Galata
Aslında iklima gençliği konusunda Lider
bir karakter oluştu Ve eminim İçinizde
de birçok graten vardır diye ben
düşünüyorum Çünkü bir Uyanış yarattı çok
gençti ama ruhu inançlarıyla birlikte
cesaretiyle birlikte siz yaş grubunuz
için Burası Z kuşağı galiba çok büyük
bir Uyanış yarattı ve z kuşağından olan
beklentiyi de artırdı aslında
ben ismim Havva her gün 20 senedir
sürdürülebilirlik konularını detayında
çalışıyorum birçok başlık altında
tecrübem var Anlat tecrübem İnşaat
endüstriyel projeler ve işletmeler
şeklinde
Ben sürdürülebiliği nereden öğrendim
Aslında Sürdürülebilir belki son dönemde
pandemi ile birlikte çok popüler bir
kelime olsa da aslında tarih boyunca
hayatımızda olan bir konu mesela
mitoloji eğitimleri de alıyorsunuzdur
belki veya tarihi eğitimleri işte
mitolojide tanrılar birbirine kızıyor
Fırtınalar çıkartıyor kuraklıklar
oluşturuyor Nuh'un gemisinin taşındığı
süreç var aslında orada da iklim
krizlerinden bahsediyor Nuh'un gemisinde
ne yapıyorlar Çok şiddetli bir iklim
krizi başlıyor ve insanlar bulunduğu
bölgeden gemi ile birlikte
taşınmak zorunda kalıyorlar
Sürdürülebilir kelimesini her ne kadar
yeni konuşuyor olsak da tarihler boyunca
ve bize anlatılan hikayelerde de
gördüğümüz gibi hep bir iklim krizi hep
insanların maruz kaldığı sıkıntılardan
bahsedilen Hikayeler var benim kelimem
Aslında oldukça zor ama anons yapan
arkadaş çok kolay söyledi Demek ki Z
kuşağı için düzgün bir kelime seçmişiz
şimdi bu kelimeyi seçerken Aslında biraz
İroni yapmak istedik Sürdürülebilir
kelimesi o kadar yaygınlaştı ki altı
biraz boşaltıldı maalesef Sürdürülebilir
konusu son derece bilimsel inançları
gerektiren
inandığını yapmayı gerektiren bir konu
altı çok boşaltıldığı için bize hem bir
yere inanarak ya da inanmayarak şu
kelimeyi söyledik sürdürülebilirlik
değiştirebildiklerimizden misiniz diye
ben bu kelimeyi söylerken oldukça
çalıştım öncesinde ama benim ekibimde
Sizin yaş grubunuza yakın kişiler var
onlar işte sonra da burada geldikleri
için teşekkür ediyorum sizi anlatmak
istediğim şey İyi olan kazansın iyi olan
nedir onun tarifi benim dünyamdaki olan
nedir sizin için iyi olacak nedir
Aslında neyin kazanması gerekiyor Neye
devam dememiz gerekiyor onu anlatmak
istiyorum şimdi sürdürülebilirlik bir
maratondur dedik ben bu maratonun ne
zaman başladım ben Çevrim mühendisiyim
Terim mühendislikten mezun oldum çevrem
hangisinde de tabi sürdürülebilliğe
yönelik birçok eğitimler aldık işte
iklim krizine ekosistemi biyoçeşitliliğe
yönelik hava kirliliğine yönelik ama
bu sürdürülebilirliği hem iş hayatında
hem de okulda aldığım eğitimden ötesinde
aslında Ben sürdürülebilirliği
babaannemden öğrendiğimi fark ettim
Neden babaannemden öğrenmişim Benim
babaannem doğanın içinde yaşayan doğaya
Aşık Aslında doğayla konuşan bir kadındı
Benim babaannem Ben de küçükken Onun
yanına çok sık giderdim Anadolu'da
büyüdüm inanılmaz kır Çiçeklerin içinde
koşardım Düşünsenize ussuz bucaksız kır
çiçekleri ve sürdürülebilirlik konusunu
Aslında detaylar orada aşık olmuştum
Benim babaannem bana Ne derdi Derdi Ki
şey işte Torun olarak Dereleri kirletme
Çünkü ileride bu Derelerden canlanan su
içecek karıncalara basma Çünkü onların
çocukları var evlerini yemek götürüyor
çiçekleri kopartmak Çünkü çiçekler
insanlar için yaratılmadı doğa için
yaratıldı ve ondan yaşam hakkı var derdi
her şeyin fazlası zehir derdi yani fazla
tüketme fazla konuşma fazla depolama
derdi Mesela ben hayatım boyunca
maalesef fazla depolamış birisim ve
bundan vazgeçmeye başladım
sürdürülebilirliği benimsedikçe Aç
insanları düşün komşun açken senin Tok
yatman Aslında kabul görür değil derdi
ve paylaşmayı öğren derdi Sürdürülebilir
temel kavramlarından biri paylaşmaktır
sosyal kapsamda ve en önemli şey aslında
İpek hocamın da belirttiği gibi dengede
ol derdi Sen bir ilişki içinde yaşayan
bir canlısın ne ile ilişki içindesin
doğayla ilişki içindesin toplumla
ilişkiyi içindesin sadece kendine olan
fayda iyi değil aynı zamanda topluma
çevreye ekosistemi olan faydayı da
düşünerek yaşa ki bir dengede ol bu
öğretiler sonrasında Açıkçası ben
doğadaki her şeyim benim arkadaşım
olduğunu düşünüyordum ve arkadaşlarımla
çok mutlu geçirmeyi düşünüyordum onların
yararına faydasına bir şeyler üretmek
benim hedeflerimden biriydi
benim dönemimde başarılı öğrenciler Ben
başarılı bir öğrenciydim açıkçası
başarılı Öğrencilerin velileri hep
çocukların Doktor olmasını isterdi ben
bir ara Doktor olmayı düşünmedim değil
açıkçası ne yapmak istiyordum Doktor
olunca yine fayda öğreteceğim işte
kanserep çözüm bulacağım bir Türkan
Saylan olacağım işler yapmak isterdim
ama sonra aynı şeyi düşündüm dedim ki ya
benim arkadaşlarım doğadaki
arkadaşlarımda hastalandı Ben ne yapayım
dedim arkadaşlarıma da çare bulmam lazım
bir ve çevrem mühendisi olmaya karar
verdim Çok bilinçli bir tercih yaptım
dedim ki arkadaşlarım hastalanmaması
için zarar görmemesi için doğadaki
arkadaşlarımın sistemi değiştirmem
gerekiyor Mühendislik çözümleri bulmam
gerekiyor ve bilimsel hareket etmem
gerekiyor dedim ve çevre mühendisliğini
seçtim şu an neredeyim şu an dediğim
gibi 20 senelik bir Sürdürülebilir
tecrübem var aslında ve kurumsal bir
yapının içinde Ee çevreye yönelik
Sürdürülebilir ve yönelik kültürünü
oluşturulması yapılan her aksiyonda her
aktivitede
sürdürülebilirliğin içinde olduğu
konular için
kararlar verilmesini değer olarak
yaratılmasını sürdürülebilirliğin
attığımız her adımda bir sistem
kurulması ve bilimsel olarak
Sürdürülebilir uygulanması için destek
amaçlı bir pozisyondayım
biri büyük ihtimalle sürülebilir
Kalkınma amaçlarını görmüşsünüzdür diye
düşünüyorum sürdürülebilir kalkınma
amaçlarına bakınca ne görüyorsunuz
mesela Birincisinde diyor ki yoksulluğa
son
ikincisinde açlığa son diyor
bir işte toplumsal cinsiyet eşitliğinden
bahsediyor
14'te Sudaki canlıları koruyalım diyor
13'te İklim eyleminden bahsediyor
aksiyon planlar oluşturacaksın artık
diyor sürdürebilir kalkanın amaçları
konusunda büyük ihtimalle dersleriniz
vardır amaçlarını birleşmiş milletleri
tanımlıyor birleşmiş milletleri diyor
ki; Ben diyor kurumlara devletlere diyor
yol gösterici olmak için diyor bazı
diyor ana noktalarda diyor
sürdürülebilirlik amaçları hedefleri
tariflemem gerekiyor Şu anda 17 tane
gözükse de aslında 150 tane alt maddesi
var Yaklaşık buraya baktığımızda Aslında
Ne diyor benim babaannemle aynı şeyi
söylüyor iyi insanı oluyor çevreyi Koru
diyor doğayı Koru diyor özüne
baktığımızda Kalkınma hedefleri diyor ki
her şeyin iyisini yap diyor attığın her
adımda birey olarak da diyor şirket
olarak da diyor dünya olarak da diyor
İyi olanı fayda olanı faydalı olanı üret
diyor
benim elimde sihirli bir değnek olsa
acaba Hani hangi konuda Sürdürülebilir
Kalkın amacı tarifler hangi konuda Hedef
belirlendim dersem mesela yoksulluğa son
vermek isterdim açıkçası öncelik olarak
iklimi değiştirmek isterdim Çünkü bütün
dünyayı etkiliyor ve dünyanın sonu
iklimden gelecek diye maalesef Hani
birçok varsayım var ve gerçekleşme
ihtimali yüksek
cinsiyet eşitliğini dengelerde
ayrımcılığa son verirdim
sihirli bir deneyimim olsa en önemli
şeylerden biri de nitelikli eğitim
sağlardım Yani şu anda sizin burada
aldığınız nitelikli eğitimi dünyanın
birçok yerinde maalesef çocuklar
alamıyor ve Dünya bu yüzden de aynı
zamanda kalkınmıyor ve etik hareket
etmiyor diye düşünüyorum
ve sürdürülebilir kalkınma amaçları
deyince lütfen aklınıza İş hayatınızda
çok karşınıza çıkacak hep iyi olana
anlattığını iyi insan olmanın
temellerinin
verdiğini ve iyi şirket olmanın
temellerini içerdiğini unutmayın hep iyi
olanı seçin O nedenle
Şimdi ben size belirttiğim gibi temel
sürdürülebilirlik konusunda çalışıyorum
şirkette Kurumsal şirket kurumsal
sürdürüle birlikte kurumsal
sürdürülebilirlik sürdürülebilir
kalkınma amaçlarını içeren Ama onun
üstünde bazı kapsamları olan bir çalışma
Biz kurumsal sürdürebileceğiz olarak
İngilizcesi evin arması olarak Aslında
daha çok karşınızda ESG logosu çıkabilir
adlandırıyoruz çevrenin başlığı altında
beni işimde sadece iklim değişikliği yok
çünkü iklim değişikliği çok önemli bir
parametre ama iklim değişikliğini
tetikleyen ve rahat bir oda Ayvalık var
biyoçeşitlilik var canlıların yok olması
da biliyorsunuz iklim değişikliğinde çok
önemli bir etken su kullanımı var su
kullanımının azaltılması su
kaynaklarının korunması denizlerin
kirletilmemesi konusu var iklim
değişikliği planları yapıyor benim
yaptığım görevde Eee ve şu an birçok
projemizde ciddi bir şekilde somut
Bilimsel verilere dayalı iklim
değişikliği planları yapmak zorundayız
atık yönetimini yap diyor yenilebilir
enerji kaynakları seç diyor mesela
birçok artık projemizde güneş enerjisi
ile rüzgar enerjisi kullanma yoluna
gidiyoruz Çünkü artık biliyorsunuz kömür
çok ciddi bir kirletici ve kömür
kullanımını yasaklanmasını talep
ediyoruz ve bizim en önemli
şeylerimizden bir tanesi kültürel mirası
ülkemiz o kadar değerli ki proje
Yaptığımız her noktada çok kazı
yapıyoruz şimdi İnşaat sektöründeyim ve
kazılan her noktadan neredeyse Roma
imparatorluğundan Osmanlı
İmparatorluğu'ndan eserler çıkıyor ve
kültürel miras da aslında
sürdürülebilirliğini çok önemli
kalemlerinden biri Şimdi ben çevremin
mühendisliği olarak sizlere sunum
yapıyorum ama sürdürülebilirlik her
branşın Aslında
ilgilenmesi gereken ve sorumluluk
duyulması gereken bir konu şirketlerde
de genelde Sürdürülebilir komiteler
tarafından yönetilir ve farklı
branşlardan insanlar olur Sosyal konular
çok önemlidir sosyal konuların içinde ne
var İnsan hakları konusu var sürdüğünde
bile aslında temelinde Az önce sürdüğü
bir Kalkınma hedeflerinde de gördüğümüz
gibi
insan hakları dayalı iyi insan olmaya
yönelik birçok hedefler belirlememizi
istiyor Bizim scopumuzda içeriğimizde
insan hakları hangi başlıklar altında
var mesela çalıştırdığımız işçileri Çok
doğru ortamlarda standartları yüksek
ortamlarda mutlu olabilecekleri konforlu
çalışabilecekleri ortamlarda çalıştırmak
zorundayız çalışanlarımızın iş
güvenliğini düşünmek zorundayız
sağlığını düşünmek zorundayız cinsiyet
eşitliğine yönelik projeler yapmak
zorundayız nedir kadınlara daha
yeterince istihdam şansı fırsatı
yaratmak zorundayız kadınların
güçlendirilmesi konumda projeler
kadınların eğitilmeleri konusunda
projeler yapmak zorundayız sosyal
başlıkta çevre başlığı kadar Aslında
sürülebilir konusunda içinde yer alan
konulardır Mesela bir proje yapıyorsunuz
yaptığınız projenin Eee bölgede ki
halkın da bir etkileşim var bölgedeki
halka iş imkanı sağlamak zorundasınız
sosyal anlamda da sürdürülebilirlik bunu
destekleyen bir konudur kısa göstermek
istediğim bir konu var varsayalım Sizler
İnşaat mühendissiniz ve bu konuda
bir proje yapıyorsunuz demiryolu projesi
yaptığınızı düşünelim Bu projenin
Sürdürülebilir olabilmesi olabildiğini
söylemek için az önceki başlıkların
hepsini tek tek inceleyip
sürdürülebilirlik gereksinimlerine veya
doğaya olan etkileşimi sosyal anlamdaki
etkileşim nasıl yönettiğinizi ispatlamak
zorundasınız Diğer türlü artık zaten
dünya o kadar değişiyor ki Finans
şirketleri size form sağlamamaya para
kaynağı sağlamamaya başlıyor mesela
böyle bir projede yaptığımızı
sürdürülebilirlik etkenleri ne oluyor
halkla olan ilişki ekonomik katkı
bölgede böyle bir proje yaptığında halka
iş imkanı sağlıyorsun endemik türlerin
korunması var toprağın doğanın suyun
içinde nesli tükenmekte olan bitkiler
var bunların korunması var
Mesela az önce sel felaketlerinden
bahsettik bu projedeki en önemli
Sürdürülebilir konulardan bir tanesi
yapılan projenin sel felaketlerine karşı
dayanıklı iklim krizlerine karşı
dayanıklı olması lazım ki uzun ömürlü
olsun ve halk zarar görmesin benim
sürdürülebilirlik dediğim kurumsal
olarak ele aldığım birçok ana başlık var
ve bunların yönetilmesi için hepsini
düşünmek hepsini nasıl koruyacağımı
dünyaya topluma çevreye nasıl faydalı
olacağımı ispatlamam lazım ki
şirketlerin de sürdürülebilirliği devam
etsin yoksa Finans şirketleri bize bu
anlamda da destek vermiyor Ben size çok
kısa bir video göstermek istiyorum bizim
gerçek bir videomuz bu Az önce
gösterdiğim alanda kazı çalışması
yapmadan önce bir o çeşitliliği
canlılara değilse tükenmekte olan
çalışan canlıları korumak amaçlı
[Müzik]
çalıştığımız alanda
tükenmekte olan bitkileri ve canlıları
kurtarmamız gerektiğini
önce alana girmeden önce bu canlıları
tespit
ediyordu gördüğünüz gibi işte
Köstebekler var nesli tükenmekte olan
[Müzik]
yılanlar var bunların yaşam
yaşamlarına zarar vermemek için
[Müzik]
sağladık ve biyoçeşitliliği Bu anlamda
destek verdik Şimdi ben
sunuma başlarken İyi olan kazansın dedim
iyinin tanımı neydi çevre ve sosyal
anlamda halka
çalışanlara katma değer sağlayan
Öncelikle kendinize de katma değer
salgılamanız gerekiyor tabii dünyaya
değer katan her şey iyiydi ve dünyaya
biz nasıl değer katabiliriz verdiğimiz
kararlarla değer katabiliriz ileride
hepiniz birer yönetici olacaksınız Anne
baba olacaksınız öğretmen olacaksınız
Mühendisler olacaksınız avukatlar
olacaksınız verdiğiniz her karar
Öncelikle Eee dünyaya katma değer
sağlayacak şekilde olması gerekiyor
tüketim alışkanlıklarınızı değiştirerek
katma değer sağlayabilirsiniz Doğal olan
ilişkinizi gözden geçirebiliriz nedir
doğal olan ilişkimiz nerede fayda nerede
zarar üretiyoruz fayda kısmını tercih
edebiliriz ve örnek
bireyler olabilir sizden sonraki gelecek
nesillerde var Sizden önceki nesiller de
var Yaptığımız her şeyde
sürdürülebilirlik anlamında örnek
olabiliriz
ve hep iyi seçin diyorum hep iyi olun
hep katma değer katacak şekilde yaşayın
hep ruhumuza işlesin diyorum Teşekkür
ediyorum
Sağ olun
[Müzik]
teşekkürler
[Alkış]